[Musique]
c'est un projet avec les enfants en
difficulté et plus dans les garder
jusqu'à ce que je trouve indécent c'est
tout c'est tout mais ici pour travailler
quelque chose d'essentiel la
communication mossé communiqué nation
j'avais envie qui reste jusqu'à la fin
juste si j'ai remplacé
[Musique]
c'est à projets avec des enfants en
difficulté et watrigant les garder
jusqu'à ce que je trouve des remplaçants
ok je n'aurais pas dû faire en sorte
bonjour d'habitude les gens comme y
répondre on va voir comment il se sent
il a de la ressource
moi je vous apprendre des vrais trucs
qui vont nous servir dans la vraie vie
brossez vous les dents les esclaves à
l'époque c'était en fonction de leur
banque ont décidé et rester en vie ou si
on les tuait surtout toi on sait jamais
ils vous ont déjà eu une fois ça peut se
reproduire
on est ici pour travailler quelque chose
d'essentiel la communication commençait
comme août et ma soeur me regarde ses
visions
tex quoi h opel les hopla j'ai pas le
temps chez moi d europe là tu sois là
je connais pas vraiment votre histoire
mettons à milan je pense pas que ce soit
un bon mix en parler on lui a beaucoup
pris à ce gamin il a un bon fond
[Musique]
moi je suis pas doué pour parler aux
gens ça s'apprend jimmy pourquoi tu vas
parler six mois par les enfants de
gaulle est mort
n'oublie pas qu'un enfant qui cause des
problèmes c'est avant tout à nos
frontières
nous avons envie qu'il reste jusqu'à la
fin du stage si le remplacer
c'est marrant ils se rebiffent il
souffre en même temps lâche rien c'est
pas mal quelqu'un
une question de mentalité si tu leur
donnes siad mieux ils voudront est ce
qu'il ya de mieux soigner que je ne se
le dit pas assez mais ce que ça fait
pour moi c'est pas quelque chose que
j'oublie